und dieser freitag das ist der
schwierigste tag für olaf scholz seitdem
er kanzler ist heute erwartet
deutschland von ihm die ganze wahrheit
kein ich kann mich nicht erinnern
sondern klartext ehrlichkeit der kanzler
heute im kreuzverhör im sogenannten
comex untersuchungsausschuss diesem
riesigen steuerskandal bild wird den
ganzen tag live von dort berichten denn
dort dort soll scholz nachher alles was
er weiß auf den tisch legen
[Musik]
höllenwoche für kanzler oder scheiß der
kanzler unter druck wie nie zuvor
[Musik]
heute stolz verhör
untersuchungsausschuss zum sogenannten
comex kanal es geht um die wahre herr
bundeskanzler erinnern sie sich endlich
sagen sie die ganze wahrheit
darum geht es der hamburger warburg bank
wurden steuer nachzahlungen in höhe von
47 millionen euro einfach erlassen
damals regierte in hamburg olaf scholz
war das wirklich nicht seine
entscheidung keine politische
einflussnahme bild hat nun exklusive
einblicke in die akte comex bekommen
beweislage ist ziemlich ziemlich dicht
es wird schwierig für den bundeskanzler
die vielen widersprüche und sein
unerklärliches schweigen und vergessen
zu erklären
erst vor einer woche hatte scholz alle
unangenehmen journalisten fragen zu
seiner rolle im konnex plendl einfach
abgebügelt auch von den 200.000 euro
schließfach seines hamburger spd
kollegen cast weist der kanzler
angeblich nicht
ich habe keinen anspruch darauf dass
irgendjemand mal sagt okay zweieinhalb
jahre habe ich es versucht rauszukriegen
ich habe es nicht geschafft
der kanzler unter massiven druck in
einer höllenwoche finden nach seinem
unwürdigen auftritt mit dem
palästinenserpräsident abbas nachdem er
die ganze schuld für sein schweigen auf
sein sprecher show und dann habe ich wie
ich schon gesagt habe den fehler gemacht
nicht darauf zu reagieren bzw
nicht selber eine lücke zu lassen so
dass der bundeskanzler reagieren kann
doch scholz steht weiter im sturm
ausgebuht und nieder geburt bei einer
bürgersprechstunde im brandenburgischen
neuruppin
internationale atomenergieorganisation
zugang bekommen haben müssen zum gründe
und das wirtschaft
eine höllenwoche für den kanzler mit dem
höhepunkt heute im verhör auftritt vor
dem untersuchungsausschuss comics für
bundeskanzler scholz geht es um alles
geht für ihn um das kanzleramt es geht
für ihn um die macht und es gibt mit
möglicherweise sogar um die macht für
die sozialdemokratische partei nicht nur
in hamburg sondern in ganz deutschland
der ermäßigte mehrwertsteuersatz wird so
lange gelten wie die gast beschaffungs
umlage erhoben werden wird
der kanzler unter druck wie nie
[Musik]
der kanzler an der presse unter druck
heute von comex untersuchungsausschuss
in hamburg dort bild reporterin nadja
aswad ich grüße dich nadja schönen guten
morgen was ist die wichtigste frage auf
die scholz bisher nicht geantwortet hat
guten morgen kai die wichtigste frage
ist tatsächlich ob bundeskanzler olaf
scholz sich heute erinnern kann weil wir
erinnern uns er tut es nicht und bislang
ist das einzige was wir von ihm dazu
gehört haben dass ihm die konkrete
erinnerung fehlt er hatte auch anfangs
treffen mit dem warburg beim christian
olearius vergessen dann haben
kalendereinträge gefehlt das wurde alles
nach und nach eingereicht das erinnert
ein bisschen an die salami taktik die
wir manchmal kennen aus der politik und
tatsächlich ist aber zwischenzeitlich
auch aus aufgetaucht ein protokoll aus
dem finanzausschuss des bundestages das
als vertraulich und geheim eingestuft
wurde da steht drin dass der kanzler als
er noch finanzminister war und dort
befragt wurde nämlich im april nicht
stimmt gar nicht im juli im juli 2020
dass er damals gesagt hat dass christian
olearius lediglich seine sicht der dinge
geschildert habe und es ist natürlich
ein unterschied ob ich sage ich kann
mich an das gespräch nicht erinnern oder
jemand hat mir seine sicht der dinge
geschildert aber ich habe dazu nichts
gesagt und olaf scholz beruft sich
darauf dass seit zweieinhalb jahren
ermittelt würde und eben nichts
konkretes feststünde dass man das auch
mal berichten sollte fakt ist aber auch
mal kann er sich erinnern und dann
offenbar wieder doch nicht deswegen ist
das die wichtigste frage was ist bei den
treffen passiert weiß er dass jetzt
wieder ja und vor allen dingen weil
ehrlichkeit im glaubwürdigkeit natürlich
so wichtig sind gerade in der politik
was bedeutet dieser tag für die frage ob
olaf scholz ein ehrlicher mensch ist
das ist in der tat eine schwierige frage
weil wir wissen olaf scholz ist anwalt
wir wissen auch der ist schon sehr sehr
lange berufspolitiker da wird sich dann
nicht einfach in die karten schauen
lassen alle sagen immer ach comics das
ist so schwierig zu verstehen die
meisten menschen begreifen dass gar
nicht dass alles ganz kompliziert man
kann das kaum erklären fakt ist aber
auch es gibt unterlagen und es gibt sehr
detaillierte aussagen von herrn olearius
in seinem tagebuch und es wirkt
natürlich komisch wenn man sich dann als
bundeskanzler oder bundesfinanzminister
mal erinnern kann mal nicht und das ist
ein ganz ganz ganz großes problem weil
glaubwürdigkeit in der politik steht wie
du schon richtig sagt schon lange in der
kritik und in der frage und das passiert
jetzt auch gerade den bundeskanzler dank
einer das war hat unsere bild reporterin
in hamburg du wirst heute für uns den
ganzen tag diesen so wichtigen diesem
schicksalstag für olaf scholz für uns
begleiten danke dir und jetzt bei bild
live der mann der olaf scholz heute die
ganze wahrheit entlocken will entlocken
muss kurz wiese für die cdu sitzt er in
diesem hamburger comex
untersuchungsausschuss schönen guten
morgen herr wiese wie bringen morgen
kanzler heute dazu sich zu erinnern also
alles auf den tisch zu legen ja der
kanzler muss in der tat jetzt die volle
wahrheit erklären nicht mehr schreibt
viel weise dinge gerufen und da haben
wir einen fragenkatalog vorbereitet die
in videos verarbeiten werden der
kanzlerin stanford geben müssen und was
wird in diesem fragenkatalog die aller
aller wichtigste frage was sein heute
für sie
was war der hintergrund warum hat man
sich zu einer zeit als gegen die bank
bereits ermittelt wurde als sie
durchsucht worden war mit den bankern
christian olearius und max warburg im
bürgermeisterzimmer getroffen vorher
wollten die betriebsprüfer die steuern
von barig zurückfordern hinterher wurde
das fallengelassen und 47 millionen euro
sollten ende 2016 in die regierung
laufen das ist völlig unglaubwürdig dass
es nicht aufgeklärt und dazu muss sich
olaf scholz freute dass hieß es ja auch
schon in den vergangenen wochen
vergangenen monaten ja vergangenen
jahren und er hat uns und hat sie immer
abblitzen lassen und hat in ganz
wichtigen momenten dann gesagt ich kann
mich nicht erinnern was machen sie was
ist ihre taktik für heute dass der
kanzler dass mit ihnen heute nicht
wieder macht ja sogar nachher dabei sein
wir werden ihnen da festnageln und wir
waren ganz konkret nachfragen und
schauen sie es ist so dass die
finanzbeamten auch die aus dem
mitglieder des senats die befragt worden
sind auch diejenigen die dazugehören
sagt hans gar
keinen na das ist ja im grunde genommen
zu erwarten gewesen aber die
oberstaatsanwälte aus köln hat gesagt
sie muss hier ermitteln und sie hat
beschlagnahmen und dazu haben wir auch
in dieser woche dieser weitere
informationen bekommen das
bundesfinanzministerium hat eine
anweisung an hamburg gegeben ein
singulärer vorgang erst die steuern hier
nacherhoben werden im jahr 2017 nicht
wieder in die verjährung laufen können
und da sehen wir dass die wahrnehmung
hier im senat bei olaf scholz bei peter
tschentscher dem heutigen bürgermeister
und damaligen platz hatte eine selektive
ist und das wird heute dann sozusagen im
ausschuss vor den augen der
öffentlichkeit weiter aufgeklärt werden
müssen ist scholz für sie an ehrlicher
mensch
ja das wird sich heute zeigen anhand
dieses dieses beispiels ich werde den
bundeskanzler heute auf eure ehrlich
alle fakten auf den tisch zu legen danke
herr wiese
[Musik]